Make no mistake: Mowgli: Legend of the Jungle
may be based on The Jungle Book, but it's
definitely not for children.
When Andy Serkis announced his plans to direct
a live-action adaptation of The Jungle Book,
no one batted an eyelash.
Disney's 1967 animated original was an instant
classic, with wholesome elements that viewers
of all ages could enjoy, folded into a story
of self-discovery.
Wouldn't Serkis' adaptation be just as delightful?
Unfortunately, things panned out poorly for
Mowgli.
Not only did it bomb with critics when it
launched in a limited theatrical run at the
end of November, it also went over terribly
with a certain subset of its audience when
it hit Netflix on December 7th, 2018.
Parents discovered that, not too unexpectedly
given the films' PG-13 rating, Mowgli is riddled
with violence against humans and animals,
soaked with bloodshed, and features a horrifying
death that is continually referenced throughout
the narrative.
Those parents and guardians have come forward
to let others know that Mowgli is, quote,
"traumatizing," and that they shouldn't let
their kids watch a second of it.
One viewer wrote on Twitter, in part,
"#Mowgli what…the…f---???"
"That twist is some sadistic s---.
I mean, kids would be traumatized."
Another tweeted,
"Dang.
This #Mowgli adaptation on Netflix is not
really a kid's movie.
It's got some harsh scenes."
One parent alerted others of a particular
scene's potentially psychologically damaging
effects, saying,
"There is a scene in #Mowgli that will absolutely
scar and shock young kids.
Parents be warned.
This version is incredible but VERY dark."
Plenty more on social media have warned that
Mowgli is "not for kids" and will take you
by surprise with how dark it is, and that
if they were a child watching Mowgli, they
would be forever haunted by a certain character's
creepy eyes.
It seems that many parents, likely rundown
in chasing after their children all day or
clocking in eight hours at the office that
day, figured that Mowgli would be appropriate
for the whole family and immediately pressed
"play" on Netflix without a second thought.
Sadly, they unknowingly bit off far more than
they or their kiddos could chew.
While parents have been warning others to
steer clear of Mowgli when their kids are
around now that the film is on Netflix, critics
were doing exactly that when the film was
still in theaters.
A review on Decider warned,
"The action scenes where Mowgli is in danger
are legitimately scary, and probably traumatic
for very little kids, so buyer beware.
Definitely think it over before traumatizing
your kids with it […] Unless you're a giant
Jungle Book aficionado and crave completism,
you can Skip It."
The Independent called it, quote, "relentlessly,
discordantly bleak.
[…] Not quite a kid's film, not quite an
adult's one."
Just two years ago, Jon Favreau released his
Walt Disney Pictures-produced Jungle Book
to critical acclaim and immense box office
success.
"Relax, kid, no need to get worked up, kay?"
"Where am I?"
"Uh, this is a cave.
It's my cave."
The pic scored an Academy Award for Best Visual
Effects, smashed records to become one of
the top-grossing movies of 2016, and Rotten
Tomatoes summarized the film's reviews with,
"[Jungle Book is] the rare remake that actually
improves upon its predecessors, all while
setting a new standard for CGI."
It would be impossible for Serkis to replicate
the magic of Favreau's film, but it was hardly
a stretch to assume that Mowgli could pick
up praise from members of the media and make
Disney fans young and old smile.
Sadly, while a handful of reviewers have respected
Serkis' grim approach to The Jungle Book,
the general consensus is that the director
went off the deep end and made things entirely
too dark.
His desire to create something different with
Mowgli was, ultimately and unfortunately,
his undoing.